if the uk wants secure sustainable
affordable energy we're going to need
more of everything from wind turbines on
land and offshore
to acres more solar power several more
nuclear power plants and a revolution in
technologies like green hydrogen this is
actually the heart of the electrolyzer
these are called electrolyzer stacks
powered by renewable energy it can be
used for industrial fertilizer and fuel
production as well as domestic heating
and transport the rationale for green
hydrogen is about energy storage
but it's also about energy security and
as the geopolitics
of importing natural gas get more and
more difficult you have a net zero
replacement and you don't need to import
gas from places like russia
these units have a capacity of two
megawatts the government's a target for
green hydrogen is five gigawatts that's
two and a half thousand
of those it's a technology full of
potential but to deliver energy security
in the short term the uk is going to
need to rely on existing sources from
wind and solar to nuclear and some
fossil fuels a huge expansion of
offshore winds sufficient to power every
home in the country is central to the
strategy but only a limited number of
new onshore developments will be allowed
2 degrees cowardly to avoid onshore
as an issue for the conservative party
it's not a problem for anybody else i
mean it is quicker to deploy it is
cheaper it is simpler offshore
definitely has a role to play but it is
second to onshore wind in terms of all
of its benefits and in transition we'll
still need gas source from the north sea
rather than despotic regimes if possible
the government says 95 of the uk's
electricity could be low carbon by 2030
but none of these measures will make any
immediate difference to record household
bills the path to cleaner and one day
cheaper energy will be long and
expensive paul kelso sky news